et si nous parlions donc de l'avenir je
vous avais promis pour 20h25 qui les
vingt-sept donc à venir tout proche même
s'il paraît encore être du domaine de la
science-fiction un téléphone pas plus
grand qu'une télécommande du téléviseur
et avec lequel vous pourrez appeler
partout de n'importe où c'est fabuleux
et c'est pour demain 1993 reporter
marque maisonneuve
jean-françois becker plus jamais ça
finit là quand exaspéré devant des
cabines encombrer la solution un vrai
téléphone de poche bien moins coûteux
que le radio téléphone le pointait
henri sannier salut marc savard position
mais je téléphone avec un appareil mains
libres et je suis à cent cinquante
mètres d'une bande qui sert à le faire
fonctionner ça marche
soit cinq sur cinq ouais c'est bon je
peux marcher je peux marcher
j'espère que c'est une invention
française au moins en partie puisque
chaque pays d'europe aura son invention
un accord fixant la norme vient
d'ailleurs d'être signés en france le
prototype fonctionne c'est le point tel
le radio téléphone est aujourd'hui
réservé à une élite
parce que c'est une nouvelle
infrastructure qui coûtera très cher à
mettre en place le service et donc cher
ce nouveau service réutilisant grande
partie celle du réseau filaire du
téléphone de tout le monde et pourra
donc être faire une population beaucoup
plus large
les anglais plus rapide que lorsqu ils
creusent un tunnel ont déjà mis leur
propre système en service le point tel
français est encore expérimentale maison
fixe déjà une date de commercialisation
chez les fabricants de 91 france télécom
va tester le produit et le concept et à
partir de là le milieu d'année on pourra
eu tout pourra acheter ce produit là
dans les supermarchés dans les grands
magasins et auprès de france télécom ça
va pas être très cher pour le grand
public
le prix envisagé l'ordre de 2000 à 3000
francs plus l'abonnement et toutes les
communications à payer oui mais
l'abonnement est prévu pour aller vers
le grand public c'est à dire que les
prix des communications seront pas plus
chers que les prix les des publiphones
aujourd'hui le pointe elle coûte le
dixième du prix d'un radio téléphone et
dépend de bornes facile à placer est
difficile à vandaliser avoir un point
tel ce n'est plus avoir le téléphone
c'est avoir son téléphone
[Musique]